[Music]
this time you see a teenager we will
kill it
wait wait
watching Andrews no we only look young
but but really we're 40.
[Music]
they're aged yeah I mean we we eat young
Souls all the time that's well just like
you guys that's what we brought you back
you are our idols
[Laughter]
and great news you don't even have to
brew the potions anymore you could just
buy them oh buy them buy them yes we
have we have a whole Youth and beauty
industry you know shops where you can go
buy all sorts of serums and and lotions
of lotions like potions potions forever
[Music]
[Music]
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting happy 16th
birthday child
I have a gift from my favorite customers
Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her powers
Gilbert where did you get that candle we
have to get out of here which it'll be
here any seconds the book is alive he
woke up
if we intend to live past Sunrise we
have to steer this so whoa whoa wait can
we talk about this no
Not freak out the provincial Maniac
obsessed with getting revenge on Salem
so
we should get some salt why so it tastes
better when they eat us
[Music]
[Music]
that's not Six Feet Under
oh I am a good zombie
[Music]
thank you